another topic that loomis got into
and we have the stories at pft with the
full quotes i'm not going to read
anything verbatim in part because i
don't have it in front of me but mickey
loom has talked about the two main
candidates to become quarterback of the
team this year starter who will it be
will it be taysom hill will it be jameis
winston winston became a free agent
after the 2020 season he signed a deal
that pays him less than what taysom hill
is due to make this year i don't know
that that really matters here's what i
go back to
in 2020 when drew brees got injured
remember he had i think more broken ribs
than there are ribs in the human body
but when brees got injured
and we spent a whole week
thinking
based on reporting that was being done
at the time that jameis winston would be
the starter and then all of a sudden
we find out friday of
the week in advance of i think it was a
game against the falcons
that taysom hill would get the nod
what sean payton eventually said
at that time in that general
period
was that he had given his word to taysom
hill
that if brees got injured during the
2020 season hill would get the
opportunity to replace him he had made
that promise to taysom hill because the
year before obviously it was teddy
bridgewater who went 5-0
while drew brees was injured he had that
thumb injury that he suffered against
the rams i believe it was so
last year
hill
had been given that promise and remember
hill
signed a new contract in the offseason
was going to be a restricted free agent
had to decide to stay with the saints
reup with the saints
and i think part of that conversation
was
as
peyton told the world he'd given
hill his word that he'd get the chance
if brees got injured but at that same
time
peyton also said
he'd promised jameis winston he'll have
a chance to compete for the starting job
in 2021 now that was kind of odd at the
time because winston's only under
contract through 2020 but it it made it
clear that the saints wanted to bring
winston back winston became a free agent
no one flocked to try to sign him to the
kind of contract that would make him a
clear-cut starter like the panthers did
with teddy bridgewater in 2020
so winston returns and i think that he's
been promised multiple times now he gets
a chance he gets a chance to compete and
we'll find out who the better option is
now if you go with winston you still
have the taysom hill package that's an
attraction that actually hurts hill the
fact that he can do all those other
things about which loomis rave to adam
shine hurts him in the competition to be
the starter because hey if it's about
putting your best 11 on the field let
winston play quarterback let taysom hill
be the jack of all trades and do
different things
but however it plays out they're gonna
go with the guy that they think gives
them the best chance to win and
it could be something that's decided on
a week-by-week basis it could be
something that's decided on a drive-by
drive or play-by-play basis but it will
be a fair competition i believe and i
think sean payton will go with the guy
that he thinks deserves to play and it
may not be
a 17-game decision that's made week one
against the green bay packers and the
other factor sims and i have talked
about this on pft live
payton has that proclivity
of coming up with plays anywhere and
everywhere up to and including kickoff
sunday morning breakfast got some new
plays that i came up with here they are
which guy is going to be better suited
to adapting to those plays to
incorporating those plays and performing
them the way that sean payton wants them
to be performed brees could do it
hill's been around to watch it but
winston was too remember how emotional
winston was when brees retired how much
winston learned last year about how to
be a pro
one of the things about being a pro is
being flexible and adaptable you never
know what's going to get thrown at you
you have to just keep going
you just keep going no matter what the
potential distraction may be no matter
what the challenge may be and one of the
biggest challenges of playing
quarterback for sean payton
being ready on sunday morning to find
out that the game plan has been expanded
by several more plays
it'd be fun to watch because look bottom
line is
saints continue to be a contender
in the nfc this is nothing against drew
brees our new nbc colleague but
it's no secret the arm strength wasn't
what it used to be later in his career
with hill and winston the arm strength
is there
and
the farther down the field that the
quarterback can throw the ball
the more of the field that the defense
has to defend
it's a testament
to how good drew brees is at diagnosing
and executing the plays that are called
in obvious partnership with sean payton
that that offense can operate at a very
high level even though the defense
doesn't feel compelled
to cover all the way to the goal line
now this year you add in the reality
that
if you creep up to the line of scrimmage
someone may run right by you and that
ball is going to go over the top and
it's not going to be
underthrown it's going to land right in
the hands of the wide open receiver
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports